ideologies are fragmented religions
essentially they used the same symbolic
understructure but they only tell part
of the story I could give you a quick
example of that do it very quickly so um
when the American West was settled it
was settled on the on the wave of an
ideological story and here's the story
heroic individual that's positive
bringing positive culture that's the
wise King into virgin or into chaotic
territory that's the negative mother
essentially so that's positive
individual positive culture negative
nature right and that's that's a
motivating story man to bring heroically
bring order into the untamed wilderness
it's like a million people a year from
Europe come driven by that narrative
it's okay well here's the counter
narrative raping and pillaging
individual bringing the desolations of
tyrannical culture into the virginal
wonderful environmental what would you
call it yes of nature that's like yeah
man you can get a long way for that
story too but they're both half the
story
so you just put those two things
together and you have a religious story
it's like well they individual is heroic
but also is an adversary and a cruel
adversary at that culture is the wise
King but it's also the evil tyrant and
nature is beautiful and wonderful French
impressionistic landscape and cancer and
Anopheles mosquitoes and the
elephantiasis and so if you are properly
oriented in the world you tell yourself
both those stories and you say oh my god
they conflict it's like yeah they do man
that's exactly right okay so an ideology
just pulls out a subset of the religious
characters and says this is the entire
reality right it's like no it's not it's
a parasitical it's a parasitical meme
right essentially an ideology is a
parasitical meme on a religious
substructure